Well, let's see if we're right with these assumptions. I calculated the
t-statistic for each one of these also using r. Use these to calculate the p
value for each. You can do this with graphpad.com quick calcs. The link is
below. After you get in to quick calcs, you need to choose statistical
distributions and interpreting p value. Then choose calculate p value from z,
t, f, r, or chi-square. You'll learn about chi-squared in the last lesson of
this course. Click Continue, enter the value of r and the degrees of freedom,
then click Compute p. Quick calcs will give the two tailed p value. So eneter
the 2 tailed P relationship here and see if it's less than an alpha level of
0.5